[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره يعقد اليوم الاحد في مدينه العقبه
الاردنيه اجتماع امني يجمع وفدا من السلطه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بمشاركه مسؤولين
امنيين من الولايات المتحده والاردن ومصر
وقال مسؤول فلسطينيون للجزيران الاجتماعيه
يهدف لتحقيق تفاهمات حول فتره انتقاليه
تضمن وقف اسرائيل الاجراءات الاحاديه من
استيطان وهدم وقت حماه لمده سته اشهر يتم
خلالها التحضير لتهدئه والانتقال الى مسار
اكثر اتساعا
وقالت الاذرع العسكريه التابعه لفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مخيم جنين ان
اجتماع العقبه الامني لا يصب في مصلحه
الشعب الفلسطيني بل يمثل خدمه مجانيه
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي واستنكرت فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مشاركه السلطه في
اجتماع في الاجتماع وقالت ان هذه المشاركه
تاتي في اتجاه المعاكس للاجماع الوطني
الرافض لها
فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه مشاركه
السلطه الفلسطينيه في الاجتماع الامني
المزمع عقده في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه
واعتبرت في بيان ان مشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه طعنه جديده لتضحيات الشعب
الفلسطيني وخيانه لتضحيات الشهداء وحضرت
فصائل المقاومه من خطوره اجتماع العقبه
وقالت انه استكمال لمخططات للتامر على
الشعب الفلسطيني واضف البيان ان المشاركين
في هذا الاجتماع خارجون عن الاجماع الوطني
ولا يمثلون الا انفسهم
اصدر قاضي التحقيق المختص في قضايا مكافحه
الارهاب في تونس قرارات بالسجن عدد من
القياديين الحزبيين والنشاطئ السياسيين
بتهمه ما تصفه السلطات بالتامر على امن
الدوله بجانبه واصل الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
تنظيمها وقفاته احتجاجيه في ولايات عده
للتنديد بما وصفه باستهداف السلطات للعمل
لقبي كما تعهد الاتحاد العام للشغل
بمواجهه ما وصفه بالاستبداد
[تصفيق]
قال المحامي كريم المرزوقي عضو هيئه
الدفاع في القضيه التي تسميها السلطات
التامر على امن الدوله قال للجزيره الهيئه
الدفاع قررت مقاطعه الترفع في القضيه
لانتفاء ابسطه شروط المحاكمه العادله
اقرر الاتحاد الاوروبي وحزمه عاشره من
العقوبات على روسيا بالتزامن مع اعلان
الولايات المتحده عقوبات جديده عليها
وتشمل العقوبات الاوروبيه قيودا على تصدير
التكنولوجيا الدقيقه وقائمه جديده من
الافراد والكيانات ذات العلاقه بالحكومه
الروسيه تشمل مسؤولين وقاده عسكريين
انتهى تعمل مجموعه العشرين في الهند دون
توصل الى توافق بشان الموقف من الحرب على
اوكرانيا وقالت الهند عقب انتهاء اجتماعي
وزراء الماليه ورؤساء البنوك المركزيه
لدول مجموعه العشرين ان جميع دول المجموعه
صدقت على البيان الذي يهدد بالحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا باستثناء الصين وروسيا
اعلن وزير العدل التركي باكير بوزدا
اعتقاله 184 شخصا بتهمه الاهمال في ملفات
المباني التي انهارت بفعل الزلزال
الجنوبيه البلاد
وارتفعت حصيله القتلى الى اكثر من خمسين
الفا بينما تم تسجيل اكثر من تسعه الاف
هزه ارتداليا حتى الان
سوريا تواصل فرق ودفاع المدني في عدد من
البلدات في غرب ادلب رفع الانقاض والكتل
الخرسانيه المتصدعه من الابنيه التي تضررت
جراء الزلزال الذي تعرضت له المنطقه في
السادس من الشهر الجاري
انتهى
[موسيقى]